hello everyone so my name is Matata Mel
I'm a developer advocate at Google and
today we're gonna talk about taking your
s we don't net apps to the next level
with Google cloud before I start my talk
I have some books Google cloud for net
developers here so if you're interested
stop by after my talk and I'll be happy
to give these away and then a little bit
of information about myself this doesn't
work so this is this is my twitter my
email and my blog if you have any
questions about any of the stuff I said
today feel free to reach out to me as I
mentioned I'm a developer advocate I'm
based in London but it's always great to
be here by the way we also have Twitter
handles windows on GCP so we're gonna be
tweeting about windows and net on Google
cloud from this hashtag and I'm gonna
also share my presentation with you on
Windows on GCP and Google next hash tags
so you don't have to take pictures if
you don't want to I'll share my
presentation all right so first of all
it's a great time to be a developer for
years and years and years by the way who
is who is not too over here
great yes so you know what I'm talking
about for years and years we've been
constrained to windows world you know we
had all this good stuff with c-sharp
visual studio powershell psycho server
and it was frustrating for me to just do
that on Windows because I had to do
stuff on Linux once in a while and I had
to switch my tools my switch my
databases all the kind of stuff but now
with asp.net core you can target Linux
with with sequel server now runs on
Linux PowerShell runs on Linux bash from
Linux runs on Windows so it is truly a
great time to adore a developer and at
Google we try we are trying to help with
this revolution with Google cloud so
this talk is about that basically I just
want to show you what kind of stuff we
are doing to help with dotnet developers
running on Google cloud so the agenda
today is first I want to I will I like
to start my presentation with answering
why first before I show you how so the
why here is that you know why should you
even care about Google cloud when it
comes to
and so I want to go through that make
sure that it's crystal clear to you guys
why you should even care about Google
cloud when it comes to net development
once we answer that question I want to
talk about moving your existing but net
apps to Google cloud so I'm gonna show
you a simple app running on my laptop
and then we're gonna look at how you can
take that app and move to Google clouds
so the point here is to show you how
easy it is basically to have what you
have today and then move it once we do
that once you have your once we have
your app running in the cloud you have
all these services and all these tools
that become available to you so we're
gonna take our application to the next
level you want to use cloud storage
we're gonna use PowerShell command last
we're gonna use Visual Studio plug-in
and we're gonna use machine learning
with vision API and speech API and just
show you how easy it is once you have
your app running in the cloud to
basically enhance your application with
the services that Google Clair cloud
provides and then finally I mean it's
fun to work on fun features but then you
need to make your application production
ready so you need to have logging in a
temporary reporting units have auto
scaling you know tell load balancing and
these are boring tasks but everyone has
to do it so I just want to show you what
kind of tools we provide to make that
easy for you so this is the agenda so
let's just answer the question first the
first question that you probably have is
you know Windows Server sequel server
asp.net on Google Cloud what's happening
right because Google is known for many
things like Google is known for machine
learning Google is known for search
Google is known for Java and Python be
supported Java and Python for a long
time App Engine we mint and go and go is
really popular now so when you think
about net and c-sharp you don't really
think about Google cloud up until
recently and I think you're right to
think that way because if you look at
the world that we lived in up until 2006
from 14 it kind of looked like this so
on one side we had the Linux world the
open-source world and the tools around
it so for language we had for languages
we had Java Python
we had Apache projects we had Eclipse
IntelliJ as IDE we had my sequel as your
sequel server you had bash for scripting
and there were a bunch of other lis
other tools here I'm just simplifying a
little bit and then parallel to that we
had the windows world now with the
windows world you had similar things so
instead of Java you had c-sharp
instead of bash yeah PowerShell instead
of SiC my sickle he had sickle server
and so on and so forth and the
unfortunate thing was that these two
worlds they existed side-by-side but
they never really interacted and that
was really frustrating for me because I
started my career as a Windows developer
I learn all these tools and then at some
point I had to switch my job so I moved
to Linux world I had to relearn
everything and you could argue which
side is better you know I have my own
opinions like for example I think
c-sharp is much better than Java for
sure but that's not the point the point
is that you know you were trying to
solve similar problems with almost
similar tools but they were slightly
different enough to make it Unknowing
for you right but things are changing if
you look at what happened in the last
couple of years it's almost like a
revolution so first oh sorry
first net when open-source in 2014 that
was big news
and then we gradually started seeing
tools moving from Windows to Linux and
from Linux to Windows like for example
OpenSSH moved from linux to window so
you could run that on Windows then we
had like Ubuntu and Debian running on
Azure after that we in 2016 it was
probably the biggest year for net and
Windows we had the flagship sequel
server now runs on Linux I mean if you
think about that like like three or four
years ago you can't even think about
that and now it runs on Linux
similarly with PowerShell the powershell
commandlets they run on Linux and then
stuff also moving from Linux so bash now
runs on Windows and lastly not lastly
but asp.net core is the most exciting
part for me so now you can write your
ace without net apps and target Linux
Windows and Mac and that is really
exciting and actually there's a talk
today later
at 2:40 on the net containers that will
cover this at the end of my session I'm
also going to point you to all the other
talks and all the other sessions that we
have on that and windows so you know
what we have and then finally the year
ended with two announcements the first
one was Microsoft joins Linux Foundation
and then Google joins net foundation I
think that was for me that was kind of
like the highlight of the year so now
when you look at the world that we're
living today we still have these two
worlds so we still have two operating
systems but then the tools and languages
around them they are much more converge
and and this is really good news for us
because all the time and effort we spend
in learning C sharp learning s without
net and learning PowerShell all that
kind of stuff now we can apply them to
to Linux and that's great news
alright so now let's talk about what
Google cloud is doing to help for this
but before I do that let's answer the
why question workforce so why should you
even deploy to Google cloud and let's
look at this question from a consumer
perspective so let's say your cloud
consumer you are shopping around and
Google cloud tells you that you should
deploy here why should you do that
there are many reasons but I think if in
my mind it boils down to three main
reasons the first is Google's
infrastructure so when you're running
your application on Google's cloud you
are basically running on the same
infrastructure that Google is running
which means that you're running on a
private network even between data
centers so if you go from one data
center to another data center you're
going through Google's own private
network which means that you have good
latency good throughput and it's very
stable so we have fast VM provisioning
so if you want a VM it it becomes
available to you within seconds and
that's really important because when
you're moving applications to the cloud
you want things to be elastic so you
want to get VMs as fast as possible and
also Auto scale auto scale is also
really important when you have lots of
load you you want auto scale to cue Ken
to add more machines and when the load
is gone you want to scale down to save
money so the auto scaling at Google
Cloud because of the network and because
of fast VM provisioning it really works
really fast and it really helps for
for scaling up and scaling around so
that's number one number two is price so
if you are shopping for something you
definitely care about price so what what
we try to do is first of all we try to
keep our prices as competitive as
possible but on top of that we have
features that we that help you to save
even more so for example if you want to
run your VM for 10 minutes you pay for
10 minutes you don't pay for the whole
hour if you use your VM for the whole
month you get automatic this gun up to
30% and you don't have to do anything
about it just detect that you run the VM
for the whole month and we give you this
gun right away if you have a VM that's
you know but also CPU and memory but
you're not really using that we detect
your load and let you know and we tell
you by the way you can scale this VM
down you can decrease the memory you can
decrease the CPU and run it cheaper
because you don't need it so we try to
detect what you need and tell you how
you can save and then the last part is
flexibility so you can have custom VMs
which means that you can say I want to
have a VM with lots of memory but not so
much CPU because that's what you need or
you can say I want a VM with lots of CPU
but not so much memory so you customize
what you need and you pay for what you
need so that's great and also in
situations where you have like a work
who work you react you or work and you
want to have VMs you know just working
from the cue we have something called
printable VMs that the these are VMs
that can come and go depending on the
load in other parts of Google cloud but
the good thing about them is they're
perfect for this work your queue
situation where you can just have 20 of
them or 25 of them it doesn't really
matter but they're all up to 80 percent
cheaper than the regular VMs so these
all combine I think is a compelling
reason why you should care about Google
as a consumer but as a developer we are
all almost all our side developers here
what's in it for you so let's look at
that from a developer's perspective so
the first thing again is deployment
options if you want to run your app you
know in a VM we have compute engine if
you switch to containers and you want to
have your con
cluster we have container engine if you
don't care about containers of VMs and
you just want to deploy your app and let
someone else take care of scaling it for
you then you have App Engine if you
don't even care about apps and you just
want to write your functions that gets
triggered by some-some trigger then you
have called functions so no matter what
you want to do at what level we have
options for you all right the second
thing is manage services so once you
have your app running in the cloud
there's all these services that becomes
available to you right away and the key
thing about these services that we try
to do is we try to make them as managed
as possible by that I mean you for
example take pops up as an example in
pops up is a publish/subscribe messaging
framework so you create a topic and then
you you push messages to the topic and
then you get messages from the topic
normally if you set up a cluster or pops
up you need to worry about machines you
need to worry about how you're gonna
globally distribute that queue and stuff
like that whereas in Google pops up
basically just create the topic and all
of the infrastructure is abstracted away
from you you don't care about how many
machines it's running on or you don't
care where it's running it's globally
scale for you automatically so this is
true for bigquery this is true for
BigTable so we try to make it as that
worthless as possible for you and
finally most importantly in my mind is
machine learning so machine learning is
really big at Google we use it in you
know most of our products and we we have
all these models built up using the data
that we have and now we are providing
that these this machine learning to you
through API so we have vision API we
have natural language processing API we
have speech API so we try to basically
make you make it really easy for you to
consume machine learning from your apps
and I'm actually gonna show you in the
demo an example of how to do that and if
you want to build your own machine
learning models you can run tensorflow
at scale using google cloud machine
learning alright so the last thing that
i want to talk about before I show you
code and demos is what options we have
as an asp.net developer when you want to
deploy to Google cloud so if you are a
traditional SEO net
person your app is running it in NSFNET
on Windows you can take that and you can
host that on compute engine and it's
good to go so it's running in compute
engine in a VM in Google Cloud and the
sample that I'm gonna show today is
gonna show how to do this and then if
you made the switch from a net to a
snack or running on Linux then you have
more choice you can run it on App Engine
flexible environment or you can run it
on container engine so in App Engine
flexible environment you basically take
your asp.net core app put it in a docker
container and just say to app app engine
you know just take this container and
run it for me at scale so it map engine
kind of figures out what kind of scale
do you need and it provisions machines
and any load balances and it has
versioning and it has traffic splitting
so it has all this goodness built in all
you need to do is just wrap your
application into your dough container
and just give it to it and it will just
run it at scale it's very easy and this
session in this afternoon will show this
App Engine flexible later if you want to
build your own container cluster you can
also wrap your asp.net core application
into a container and run it on Cuban it
is in container engine so this gives you
more flexibility it's more involved than
App Engine but with that you have more
facts to be thorough what you can run in
your container cluster so this is for
the App site so for data if you are
using sequel server you can take the
sequel server and run on compute engine
and we support all the versions from
2008 2016 and then we have tools so we
have a visual studio plug-in where you
can manage your Google Cloud resources
from visual studio we have lots of
libraries to talk to pretty much all
Google cloud services and then finally
we have powershell commandlets
that lets you script your access using
PowerShell so no matter what you want to
do is we don't need espenak or sequel
server
tools we try to basically make make that
available to you and there's more and
more stuff that are coming so yeah so
that was enough talk now it's time to
show you some code and some demos so in
this
firedog I want to show you a simple
application first we're gonna run it on
my laptop and then once it's working on
my laptop
we wanna I want to show you how how you
can take that application and and move
it to Google Cloud the application that
I want to show you it's it's called
contoso University maybe some of you
will know this application anyone knows
No maybe okay so contoso university it's
a fictitious university and it's a
reference application for a asp.net MVC
5 so it has it has like some simple
pages for students for courses for
instructors and it's backed by a sequel
server instance and it's using MVC
system model view controller 5 so it's
it's just a reference application
showing how to use MVC backed by a
sequel server so let's just take a look
at that quickly so in the demo I just
want to show you how this works locally
on my machine so I already have the
contoso university solution open on my
machine and as I mentioned this is an
MVC application well I already have it
running so let me just show you that
quickly here so this is running locally
on my machine if you go to students this
is showing the students it's paged you
can look at the details of the student
we have courses and then we have
instructors so it's pretty basic and
then just to show you code a little bit
so we have let's start with models so we
have models for student course
Department if we look at the person for
example this has you know last name
first name full name and then student
extends from the person and on top of
that it adds like enrollment date
enrollment so you know which student you
know belongs to which class stuff like
that
as you know in MVC applications you have
a controller that actually controls the
model so let's look at the student
controller so in student controller
we have like basic methods - for HTTP
calls so for example if you get a detail
of a student then this method gets
called with an ID and then and then we
have a DB database object and then from
there we find a student and then we just
return the view and then we have a bunch
of other methods for create creating a
student editing a student so on and so
forth so that's we come with model
recovered controller and then we have
v-ups so if you look at the views of up
folder we have separate views for a
bunch of different things like courses
departments home but then if you look at
the student one it's basically just HTML
let's look at the details page for
example
it's basically HTML with some net stuff
scattered in there all right and then
one last thing to show you is web config
I'm sorry here so in web config there's
a local DB yeah
so the the actual database is local so
it's the sequel server running locally
on my machine but we're gonna change
that later to use a sequel server
running Google Cloud okay so this is the
app let me just go back to my
presentation quickly all right so now I
wanted to take this app running locally
and I want to push it to Google Cloud so
let's see what steps I need to do that
first I'm gonna make life easy for
myself and I'm gonna install Google
Cloud tools for Visual Studio this will
enable me to interface with Google Cloud
create VMs and stuff like that once I
have that this is a traditional asp.net
app so I need a Windows VM with ASP not
framework already installed on it right
so I'm gonna use Visual Studio plug-in
to get a VM that I need we also need a
sequel server instance because the one
that I'm using right now it's local so
I'm gonna get a sequel server instance
on compute engine and then finally I'm
gonna publish directly from Visual
Studio so for visual
I'm just gonna publish to the VM that I
just created so these are the steps so
let's just take a look so in this part
I'm gonna first let me stop this so if
you go to tools and then extensions and
updates'
this is where you can install we just do
a plugin that we have for google cloud
so I'll go here I click on online this
searches we just do your gala gallery so
here and we're just gonna type Google
Cloud and as you can see this is the
extension I want it's already installed
for me because I have it here but if
it's not you can double click and it
will install it right here and you need
to restart visual studio so once you do
that you go to tools and then you see
this Google Club tour so this is the
plug-in that basically lets you access
Google cloud first you need to add your
account so the visual studio is
authenticated with the Google cloud you
go to accounts and then Add Account this
opens a new browser and it tells me you
know it asks me which account you want
to use I want to use my development
account and then allow and now we just
do do is authorized to access my account
which is great I go back here it tells
me that your account is already here
because I already added my account here
that's ok
and now if I go to tools and Google
Cloud tools I show I do show Google
Cloud Explorer now this is me and then
these are my projects that I have under
my account I'm gonna look at the net
project that I have under here I can see
all the VM instances that I have all the
storage and sequel so there's gonna be
more stuff here your edit it's coming up
but for now we just show compute engine
quadsquad sequel but in the future you
you basically will be able to see all
your resources from here so I need to do
here is first I as I told you I need a
Windows VM with asp.net framework so
let's try to get that what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna right click here and just
say new asp.net instance
and this takes me to a Google Cloud
console and then there is something
called cloud lounger which is like a
marketplace for solutions on Google
Cloud and one of those solutions is
called asp.net framework so this will
enable me to install Windows Windows get
a Windows VM with asp.net framework with
with basically one click so I'm just
gonna say launch on compute engine and
then let's just call this SP net TCP
next San Francisco you can choose your
zone let's just choose uswest
you can customize your machine type you
have like 2008 2012 2016 I'll choose
2016 and then you can customize your
disk size all the kind of stuff and then
I just hit deploy and now within a
couple of minutes this will give me a
Windows VM with asp.net framework
installed now I already have one so let
me just show you that quickly if I go on
the compute engine I already have this
controller original as my VM so you can
actually RDP into that so let's do that
and I will enter my credentials and I'm
I just RDP into the windows VM server
that I got ready before this talk these
VMs they already have called SDK
installed and there you have server
manager so just a regular VM running in
the cloud
alright the second thing I need so this
will go on for a little bit but we'll
use this one for now the second thing
that I need is a sequel server to get
sequel server in the cloud what I need
to do is the rent now right click on
compute engine again but instead of
asp.net instance I'm gonna just say new
instance so this is gonna be a little
bit different and it takes me to the
right place again in Google Cloud
console
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna call
this instance sequel server GCP next and
then I'll choose my zone - yes West and
then the boot disk right now it's
pointing to our Linux instance
living systems I want a sequel server
instance so under here you can see all
the OS images including windows images
here but what I want is application and
then under here you have all the sequel
server instances so I'm just gonna
choose let's say sequel server 2016
standard and that's hit select and then
I can just keep the default create so
with this I'm gonna get a sequel server
within a couple of minutes running in
the cloud again I deployed this sequel
server before and then I configured it
already so let me just log in and show
you quickly how that works all right so
the sequel server instance is by default
they come with sequel server management
studio so I mean I'm in the VM right now
and as you can see this is my sequel
server instance and these are the
databases that I created for this demo
so it's pretty standard like the stuff
that you get used to but they run now
running in the cloud
alright so that's good let me get out of
here now what I want to do is I
basically want to take my app and deploy
it to to the client now right first
thing I need to do is let's go back to
visual studio now let's close this I
need to change web doc config to point
to the sequel server that's running in
the cloud instead of the local DB one so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna comment
this out and then I'm gonna add this in
so this is the the IP is the IP of the
sequel server instances where they have
running and I already created a user and
in the database there so I'm just using
that so that's that's number one and
second thing is I need to tell Visual
Studio how to publish this application
to a cloud so to do that I need the
publish settings file so I'm gonna go to
tools and show cloud Explorer so this is
the VM that I want to publish to so I'm
just gonna right click and say
save publish settings and let's just
save it to desktop so it's saved and
then I'm gonna right click on this app
and then publish and what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna just import the publish
settings that I just downloaded let's
just point to their desktop and it was
this one okay
so as you can see all the IP details and
username and password there they fill
for me let's just validate make sure
that I had the connection it's green
that's good I'm just gonna check this
guy and then hit publish now it will
wrap up my application and then it will
just publish to the VM running in Google
Cloud I should just take a couple of
seconds publish succeeded and if we go
here and then I click on the external IP
it's the same application and if we go
to students it's the same application
but it's running in the cloud and
talking to a single server also running
in cloud so that's what it takes
basically to take your application and
publish to Google Cloud so I'll go back
to my presentation
let's let's say let's do it at the end
all right so we so we moved our
application to Google cloud now I want
to take it to the next level so what I
want to do is first these students they
don't have any pictures right so I want
to add some profile pictures for
students but you should you need a space
to save them so I'm gonna use Google
Cloud storage for that so I'm gonna use
Google Cloud Search create a bucket
there and save the pictures there but
saving pictures for every single student
is gonna take a long time one by one
especially if you have a big big
University so thankfully we have
powershell commandlets that that you can
basically use to script things so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna use PowerShell
command net and move the pictures to the
bucket I want using the command lab then
you know students can be funny like they
can upload any kind of pictures so maybe
they'll try to upload like violent
pictures or other pictures and to
prevent that from happening so what I'm
gonna do is there's this a machine
learning API called vision API you can
give it an image and it gives you
annotations about the image so
everything it knows about that image and
we're gonna use that vision API to
detect if an image is violent or adult
image or something like that and prevent
that that that students from uploading
the image and then finally I want to add
some fun facts about the students so
something interesting about the student
but I want to make this so that student
can speak and we will detect from their
voice and we will convert that to text
and then we'll enter that as fun facts
doing this on your own it's not that
easy but I can use something called
speech API is another machine learning
API where you can basically pass in a
file with some sound and then it
extracts the text for you so that's what
I want to add to my application so let's
take a look at our code again
all right so what I'm gonna show you is
first let's look at the profile picture
so let me just find find the code for
that alright first I created a service
and I call the image uploader so this is
a really simple service let's see if you
can see that properly so the disturb is
one thing you're gonna notice that it's
using Google Cloud storage this is a new
gate library that you can you know
reference from your application and with
that you get access to cloud storage and
this image uploader it basically takes
in a bucket name goes in clusters you
need to have a bucket to save images and
then it creates a storage client so this
is the guy that we're gonna use to talk
to a cloud storage and then it has two
methods one method is called upload
image and the other one is called delete
image because when you delete the
student you want to delete the image as
well so the upload image is it basically
it takes in an image and it takes in an
ID so this is the ID of the student and
it called it users cloud storage to
upload the image and it basically just
says take this image save it to this
bucket with this ID and then this is the
source and make sure that the image is
publicly readable so with one call you
can basically upload the image to cloud
storage and then if you look at the
delete uploaded image it's again it
takes in an ID and then use a storage
client to delete the image so it's very
basic and and what I also changed is
that if you look at student controller I
added an image uploader and I'm gonna
talk about the safe image uploader in a
little bit and then if you look here for
example this is a great method this is
when the student is created what we are
doing is if an image has been passed
then use image uploader to upload the
image with the student ID and then this
will return you a path
it's a public URL basically and they
will set that as the student image path
all right so with that we can have
profile picture so let me just show you
how this works this is the one so I have
it running locally already I'll go to
students and let's just create a new
student and I'll just add myself as a
student and I'll talk about fun facts
afterwards but let's just choose a
picture I'll choose one of my pictures
and then let me just change this to 2017
be great so this will basically take my
picture upload it to class search and
then save it as image path and if I look
at the student list I am here and if I
look at the details
I have a picture great okay that's good
but having these pictures for each
student and uploading them one by one
it's gonna take a while right so what I
want to do now is I want to use
powershell commandlets that we have to
script this so that you can upload bunch
of images all at once when you install
Google Cloud SDK you have this command
that's by default so you have them by
default so I have it here already so let
me just show you this PowerShell command
line so it's called upload pictures and
then it it also has a pictures folder
right next to it so what we're doing
here is that I have a bucket so this is
the bucket that I want to save in cloud
storage and this is my folder or
pictures and all I'm saying is that new
GCS object so GC s stands for Google
Cloud storage so basically what this
command does is that given you know take
this folder and upload to this bucket
and make sure that they are part will be
readable and then I do this by new GCS
object and then basically just run this
and let's just do that
see how that looks so as this is working
in here if we I can show you there's a
bunch of other command words like
at GCSE bucket at GCSE object so these
are all Google Cloud powershell
commandlets that you can use in your
your scripting as you can see it's
already looking at the images and
uploading them and if we go back to our
console and I go to here and cloud
storage
I have bunch of buckets for all my
projects but the one is the one I care
about is called canto so I click here
and you can see that the default ur is
already uploaded with a bunch of
pictures and I can use these pictures
change my code so that they can refer to
these pictures and just use them alright
so the next next thing I want to show
you is so these pictures can be anything
right now so a student can upload any
kind of picture and we want to prevent
that we want to make sure these pictures
are not violent and other pictures so to
do that I want to use vision API so let
me go back to code again what I did is I
created another service called image
safety checker so this guy again first
up come on
yep all right this guy it's using the
vision API a library so it's a [ __ ]
takács again that you can install and
then it has a client again called image
analyzer client so this is the client
that you use to talk to vision API so
when we create this image safety checker
we create the client as well and then it
has a simple method called is safe so
given a file this takes the file and
then passes that to the image analyzer
client right here and then this
basically close vision API and get some
annotations about that image okay and
then the annotations they have four
dimensions adult violence spoof or
medical so what I'm doing here is that
and then these these annotations they're
in amps so they can be they can change
from very unlikely to unlikely possible
likely or very unlikely okay
so given an image it makes it tells you
this image is very likely that it's an
adult image or very unlikely that it's a
violent image stuff like that so what
I'm doing here is that I am basically
just checking all the dimensions and
making sure that their likelihood is
less than possible so that it's not
possible that they're they're adult or
violence so this method will basically
give me the safety that I need and then
what I did is that remember we had the
image uploader to upload our images I
created another one called safe image
uploader and it extends from image
uploader
and then the only thing that it adds is
that it basically has a reference to
this image safety checker and when we
upload the image instead of uploading
the image right away we call the image
safety checker and say and ask is this
image safe if it's not safe we throw an
exception and then otherwise we just
upload the image so with this I have
this safety that I need to upload my
image and then if we go to student
controller I show you before instead of
creating an and regular image uploader
I'm creating a safe image uploader so by
default I'm using this safety feature
and let me just show you how that works
so go back to my app I think it was this
one so let me edit this and then let me
just choose another image this one this
is like a guy shooting so it's kind of
violent I guess so let's see if we can
stop this from being uploaded so I
choose that it's safe and then it says
oh and I be able to save changes ba ba
ba because I had that exception because
of the exception I cannot upload the
image so it's pretty easy and then the
last thing I want to show you is the fun
facts so as you can see there are some
fun facts here that you can add some
text about the student what I want to do
is like have this record button you can
click on it and talk to it and it will
detect your voice committed to the text
and then edit here so to do that what I
did is
I created a couple more services so the
first one is called voice recorder so
this is not that interesting it
basically has a method called record
from microphone with seconds so you
could provide some seconds like say 3
seconds and it records your voice from
microphone for 3 seconds and it saves it
to a file that's all it does so there's
nothing fancy here
but then the other one voice recognizer
it's much more interesting first it's
using the Google Cloud speech library
and then it has something called speech
client so as you can see it all the
services that we have they have the same
pattern they have a nougat package and
then they have a client that you create
and then you use the client to talk to
it
so in this case is the speech client and
then it has a method called recognized
so what it does is that it basically
just using a speech client it calls sync
sync recognized async and pass in some
parameters that are usually the default
ones and then you you provide that file
path so the file path of your recording
and then this gets sent to the speech
API in Google Cloud and that returns
some results so usually when you pass in
your voice you have one result back and
you can just use that but sometimes
depending on how clear your your voices
you might have multiple results with
multiple alternatives and each
alternative has its own like confidence
level so you would look at the
alternatives and pick the one that has
the highest confidence but in this case
I'm just looking at the first
alternative and just returning that the
first one because this is just the demo
all right that's good and then what I
lastly changed is in student controller
I created a new method called record so
when you click the button it gets called
here with the student ID I find the
student and then and then I use the
voice recorder to record my voice for
three seconds that says to a file then I
pass that file to voice recognizer that
I just wrote and
just say recognize and and that gives me
from the voice the text I get the text
back and then I just said that as the
fun facts of the student okay so let's
try this out so here I'm just gonna say
something let's see if it works he is
cool oh I don't know it worked okay I'll
try one more time maybe they they might
often is not hooked him but he is cool
ah yeah you were cool so he'd save and
that's it all right
so I'll go back to my presentation and
let's see I have some time left so this
this is fun as you can see like we moved
our application to the cloud and and
with that we got all these services
almost for free and then we with a
couple of lines of code we use machine
learning for the tour to detect images
if they're you know bad images and then
we did speech to text but now you need
to take your application to the
production right we have some problems
with this application for example first
of all you don't this application just
runs on one VM in the cloud if that VM
goes down you have no way of knowing
that so what you need actually need is
health checks you need to add health
checks to make sure that you know if I'm
if your application is healthy or not
there's no login right now so you're
kind of blind thankfully or something
called stackdriver logging in google
cloud that gives you centralized logging
not just in google cloud but across
other cloud providers as well so we'll
add that right we'll login to our
application there's no error reporting
so if there's a like an error like we
don't know about that there's something
called sec driver error reporting that
basically captures all the errors in
your application and then gives you a
centralized that dashboard to look at
all your errors when they app when they
happened how often they happen stuff
like that so we'll add that and then our
application is not resilient
it's just one instance if we have more
more load coming in one instance is not
going to cover that we need multiple
instances load balanced and we need like
auto scaling actually to make this work
thankfully there's something called
instance groups in Google cloud that
makes this really easy so we're gonna
add an instance group and and have all
of this happen magically for us so just
to talk about the scaling in Google
cloud so this is what we had initially I
had my application running locally then
I pushed it to a single VM running in
Google Cloud so what you can do from
that point on is that you can take that
VM and create a snapshot out of it it's
called an instance image so this is kind
of like the snapshot or your application
and then from the image you create an
instance template so template is like a
blueprint for your application it's it's
a way of like it's a blueprint or how
you can create the same app on a
different VM so once you have the
instance template from there you can
create an instance group and this is
where all the magic happens basically
with instance group you get multiple VMs
load-balanced behind a load balancer and
they have health checks so the world
bouncer uses the health check to check
your app and then it also has auto
scaling so so if you need to have more
than one instance it will automatically
scale so instance group basically gives
you all the stuff that you need to run
your application in production so this
is what we're gonna like I'm just gonna
show you quickly one of these steps for
you to set this up alright so let me
first show you the the health check
first I for the health check I created a
new controller called ping controller so
this pink controller it's very simple
right now it basically when you when you
hit the end point you get a pong back
normally in a real world application you
want to check your dependencies and make
sure that they're healthy because you
before you can return okay but in this
case I'm just returning okay no matter
what I also created another end point
with some ID and I am just saying I'm
just throwing an error
because I want to show you how this
works in Google Club stackdriver error
reporting so I have this pin controller
and actually if I go back to my app I
think it was this one and if I do API
slash ping yeah it just tells me pong
nothing interesting but what you can do
is you can go to Google Cloud console
and under compute engine and then health
checks you can create a health check I
already have one but let me just show
you how that health check looks like you
basically just say this is my this is an
HTTP health check with port 80 and this
is the end point that I want to hit to
make sure that it's healthy and then
these are the criteria for my health
check so I'm going to check every 30
seconds and you know if if I get ok two
times I'm gonna assume that it's healthy
if I get if I get errors two times I'm
gonna assume that it's not healthy stuff
like that so what we gonna do is we're
gonna use this health check to create
our instance group and then when the
load balancer gets created with the
instance group it will use this health
check to determine what our instance is
healthy okay so that's one let me go
here second thing I want to show you is
stackdriver so let me just find the code
so first I created something called
slack driver logger
so the original logo of the application
it basically just uses trace but I don't
want trace I want my logs to go to a
central place so I can look at them
so it's truck driver all I had to do was
again use the new get package so this is
the new get package for truck driver
logging and then from there I just
create a client again it's the same same
kind of paradigm you referenced in a
good package you have a client so once I
have the client I just use this to lock
so by logging with this client I have my
logs central in Google Cloud so that's
number one
the second thing is error reporting so I
want all my errors to be caught and sent
to Google Cloud so to do that in Web API
config I just register select driver
error reporting so it's basically just
one line of code and all I'm saying here
is that when there's an exception this
kind of exception which is like the main
exception class just basically just
report that exception to this project
with to this service to this version so
everything that that's thrown from my
application will be will be caught and
sent to Google Cloud so let me just show
these quickly in the console so if you
go back to console go to a stack driver
here let's look at the log in first so
slack driver logs a lot of stuff but in
this case I my application is a GC
Google compute engine instance so I'm
gonna and and I this is my application
so this is where it's gonna walk and as
you can see here these are my logs so
these are my sequel statements from my
app so it's already going to select
driver because I implemented a driver
logger and it works and then to look at
the error reporting I'll go to error
reporting and let's go back to our apps
and just hit that endpoint that will
throw me an error so let's just say ping
one and this threw an exception yes we
are here okay continue so this threw an
exception so if we come back here and I
think I need to auto reload as you can
see just says oh it just seen this
exception and if I it's seen in
controller application version one and
if I click on it I got more details so I
only have like have it not work today
but if you have it like failing like a
month you can see like when it happened
how it happened what was the stack trace
all that kind of stuff that becomes
available to you just one line of code
you can catch all of this and then it's
right here I think this is really good
and then the last thing I want to show
you is the instance groups and
auto-scaling right so to do that what I
had to do is go to compute engine first
I need to create an
snap shot on my application so I need to
create an image so here I have images
and then as you can see there's a
contours of GCP one this is the one that
I created there instructions on how to
create this image but it's pretty basic
basically you just go to your windows vm
instance run a command and it shuts down
and then from there you just say create
an image from this persistent disk and
you have your image and you can share
that image with with you know other
people with other projects stuff like
that so once you have this image then
you need to create a template a
blueprint or how to create that image
and use it in other VMs so I have
instance templates so here this contoso
DCP template that I created before this
talk and this guy basically the
important thing is that it's using the
image I just showed you about and it's
it has some configuration that you can
set and and that's it you know there's
not much to it and then you can also
specify like what kind of AP eyes and
things that that you can use okay and
that's it so I have my template so from
this template now I can create an
instance group so I have five minutes
left so I just want to show you that
quickly in instance groups I created an
instance group and if we just edit that
instance group so this this is where all
the magic happens first
it's using the template I created and
then auto scaling is on so I just
setting this on I get auto scaling which
is great it is using load balancing so
it's HTTP load balancing on port 80 I
can specify how many instances I want by
default but minimum I have one instance
by minimum and then for this demo I set
three instances so it will also scale to
three instances but you can set that to
whatever you want and then it's also
using health check so it's using the
health check that I defined to make sure
that my instances are healthy so with
this I get pretty much everything I want
my application is much more ready to
production and we have all the pieces
basically to make this happen
so now I want to go back to presentation
and just point a couple of things before
I finish my talk so summary what do we
do
we started with an asp.net app running
locally we moved it to a Windows server
running in the
sico server running in the cloud we
added pictures with cloud storage
we added intelligence with vision API
speech API and we made a production
ready with like instance groups load
balancing auto scaling stackdriver
things like that but there's much more
so if you go to google.com slash net
slash windows there's much more
information there cold there's a collab
page but they're also called labs here
at next where you can actually do this
stuff hands-on and I'm gonna be there if
and if you have any questions I'll be
there as well
talks at next so this the first one was
my talk and then we have to talk in the
afternoon on net containers another one
at sicko server at the same time and
tomorrow we have in a windows-based talk
as well and tomorrow from 1:00 to 4:00
p.m. there's a meet the experts area and
I'm gonna be there where we're gonna
have net people basically so any
questions that you have about on
koolclap we're gonna be there and as I
said at the beginning of my talk yeah I
think it's a great time to be a
developer thanks for your time and if
you want books I have books yeah that
was it thank you
you